[Narrator:] Smart girl, Mary Sue. She's learned early to brush her teeth
the right way at the right time.
[Mary Sue stands in front of the mirror brushing her teeth.]
[Narrator:] Brush your teeth immediately after
eating.
If brushing is impossible, rinse the mouth
with water.
[Mary Sue finds a water fountain to rinse
her mouth out.]
[Narrator:] Brush the upper teeth downward,
the lower teeth upward.
For healthier teeth, a prettier smile, learn
to brush your teeth correctly.
[Mary Sue brushes her teeth happily in the
mirror and smiles.]
[Narrator:] Good food for good health. But
for good dental health,
what not to eat is also important.
[An adolescent boy sits at a dinner table
passing around a plate of chicken.]
[Narrator:] Dental scientists report that
sugar is the major cause of tooth decay.
[A bowl of caramel candy quickly evaporates.]
[Narrator:] Avoid candy and other sweet foods between meals.
Substitute fruit, nuts, or popcorn.
[The boy switches from his candy to take a
bite out of an apple instead.]
[Narrator:] Cut down on sweets. Cut down on
tooth decay.
[The boy smiles into the camera to show his healthy
set of teeth.]
[Narrator:] Johnny has a new tooth, and an
important one it is.
[Johnny looks in the mirror with his fingers
in his mouth trying to feel his new tooth.]
[Narrator:] Children's first, or baby teeth
affect general health. They're necessary as
a guide for permanent teeth to follow.
[Johnny receives a glass of milk to drink
from his mother.]
[Narrator:] For clear speech, for giving form
and symmetry to the face.
Protect your children's first teeth.
[Johnny plays with the mirror in the dentist's
hand to look at the inside of his mouth.]
[Narrator:] Help your youngster toward lifelong
dental health.
[Narrator:] Smart girl, Mary Sue. She's learned to brush her teeth the right way at the right time.
[Mary Sue stands in front of the mirror brushing her teeth.]
[Narrator:] Brush your teeth immediately after
eating or rinse the mouth with water.
[Mary Sue then finds a water fountain to rinse
her mouth out.]
[Narrator:] Brush the upper teeth downward, the lower teeth upward.
This is National Children's Dental Health week.
Your dentist says "Learn to brush your teeth correctly."
[Mary Sue brushes her teeth happily in the
mirror and smiles.]
[Narrator:] Good food for good health. But
for good dental health,
what not to eat is also important.
[An adolescent boy sits at a dinner table
passing around a plate of chicken.]
[Narrator:] Dental scientists report that
sugar is the main cause of tooth decay.
[A bowl of caramel candy quickly evaporates.]
[Narrator:] This is National Children's Dental
Health week. You can substitute fruit for
sweet foods between meals.
Cut down on sweets. Cut down on tooth decay.
[Smiling adolescent boy.]
[Narrator:] Johnny has a new tooth, and an
important one it is.
[Johnny looks in the mirror with his fingers
in his mouth trying to feel his new tooth.]
[Narrator:] This is National Children's Dental Health Week and your dentist
wants you to know that children's first teeth are important.
[Johnny receives a glass of milk to drink
from his mother.]
[Narrator:] They're necessary as guides for
the permanent which are to follow.
[Narrator:] Protect your children's first
teeth. Help your youngsters
toward lifelong dental health.
[Johnny plays with the mirror in the dentist's
hand to look at the inside of his mouth.]
[Narrator:] For sparkling teeth and a lifetime
of dental health, start dental care early.
[A woman smiles into the mirror as she watches
her daughter carefully brush her teeth.]
[Narrator:] Children who begin proper dental
care at an early age form good dental habits
that last a lifetime.
Let your child enjoy lifetime dental health
by starting proper dental care early.
This message from the Cleveland Health Council.
[Narrator:] Your Dental Society Presents...
a Good News Story about Dentures.
[Narrator:] A public service message about
dental health.
[A dentist unrolls a poster that reads "Dental Health"]
[Narrator:] First of all, follow good dental
practices so you can keep your natural teeth
as long as possible.
[An image of a toothbrush multiplies into
another toothbrush]
[Narrator:] On the other hand, if you are
unfortunate enough
to have lost your natural teeth, you can obtain substitutes.
[Three men and a woman appear smiling.]
[Narrator:] One out of four Americans is already
wearing dentures, but you'd never know it.
Modern dentures are so natural-looking. Lack
of teeth ages you, hinders your digestion,
handicaps you in many ways.
Careful study by your dentist is the first
step towards good-looking dentures
that are functional and comfortable, too.
[Narrator:] Your dentures will be designed
to meet your personal needs.
With them you'll be healthier, happier, better-looking.
You'll be your same not-so-old self once again.
[A man smiles to reveal his sparkly new dentures.]
[Narrator:] For a better life in every way,
your Dental Society urges you
to have your teeth checked regularly.
[Narrator:] Your Dental Society in cooperation
with the American Dental Association presents
"A Toothsome Tale"
The story of how man has brushed his teeth
down through the ages.
[A caveman picks his teeth with a bone.]
[Narrator:] Long ago, toothbrushes were rather
basic. Then, man began to depend on
Mother Nature. Now, we use small, straight toothbrushes.
Two of them so one of them so one will always
be dry and fresh.
Brushing top teeth down, bottom teeth up,
and carefully cleaning the insides and chewing surfaces.
[A toothbrush is shown brushing a set of teeth up, down, and then inside.]
[Narrator:] Most important of all, today,
smart people brush their teeth immediately
after every meal. And when that's not convenient,
they rinse their mouths with water.
[A man sips a cup of water in order to rinse
out his mouth after eating a meal.]
[Narrator:] So for better dental health, brush
properly and brush immediately after meals
with a good toothbrush.
[A dentist holds up a chart that list ways
to maintain proper dental health.]
[Narrator:] This public service message has
been presented by your Dental Society in cooperation
with the American Dental Association.
[A group of free-floating animated heads are talking to each other, mouths opening and closing.]
[Narrator:] These days everybody's talking
about, reading about, and hearing about diets.
[A man smokes his pipe in a chair watching
television.]
[Narrator:] Children, too, need a well-balanced
diet to promote good general health
as well as to develop healthy teeth and gums.
[A dentist inspects a little boy's teeth.]
[Narrator:] Actually, it's a simple diet.
Every day your child needs three glasses of milk.
Two or more servings of green or yellow vegetables.
Two fresh fruits, one raw, including citrus
fruits. An egg and meat, fish,
poultry, or cheese. Whole grain cereal and buttered bread.
These are the foods your children need to
develop strong healthy teeth.
[A tooth is shown with a cape on and an image of children drinking a glass of milk using straws appears.]
[Narrator:] They're good for you too. To help
prevent tooth decay, substitute fruits, nuts,
and popcorn for sweets between meals.
[Fruits and nuts are shown beside a large
bowl of popcorn.]
[Narrator:] This has been a public service
message presented to you by your Dental Society
and the American Dental Association.
[Narrator:] Introducing Liz the Quiz Whiz.
She knows all the answers in the category
of the importance of first teeth, so-called
baby teeth. Do you?
[Liz takes a bow and trumpets begin to sound.]
[Narrator:] How many teeth in the first set,
Liz?
[Liz:] Twenty.
[Narrator:] Why are these first teeth so important?
[Liz:] Scientifically speaking, the deciduous,
medial, and lateral incisors form...
[Narrator:] Yes, Liz. First teeth are important because they maintain space for your permanent teeth.
When do permanent or second teeth appear?
[Liz:] The time of incisory...
[Narrator:] Yes, Liz. The first permanent teeth, usually six-year molars,
appear at about six years of age.
Their loss handicaps a child permanently.
Children should have their first dental check-up
when they're two years old or when they have
all their first teeth.
So they'll win one of the most important prizes of all: sound, healthy, permanent teeth.
[A boy and girl smile at each other showing
their healthy teeth.]
[Narrator:] This public service message has
been brought to you by your Dental Society
in cooperation with the American Dental Association.
[An older man is shown with his dog. His mouth
appears pinched.]
[Narrator:] Poor Sam. He's worried. Sam is
a social outcast.
At work, he's no sensation either. Even though he's only thirty-five.
He loves good food but can't eat properly.
What's Sam's trouble?
Dental disease has robbed him of his teeth.
Those he has are okay,
but he just doesn't have enough of them.
[Sam opens his mouth to show how many teeth
he is missing.]
[Narrator:] With only six teeth, Sam can't
chew food well. Result, poor digestion, poor nutrition.
Sam goes to his dentist for professional advice.
His dentist tells him he needs partial dentures.
[Narrator:] Now look at Sam. Handsome, personable,
self-confident Sam.
[Smiling people stand on either side of Sam
and pin a first place medal on him.]
[Narrator:] No digestion or nutrition troubles
now.
Sam's partial dentures are comfortable, attractive, serviceable, easy to get used to.
Fact is, one out of four Americans wears dentures today.
This message has been presented by your dental society and the American Dental Association.
[Narrator:] Smile pretty, everyone. Oh, poor
Peggy. Too bad parents neglect baby teeth.
Youngsters are so sensitive about appearance.
[Peggy cries after being ashamed to smile
in her class picture because of her teeth.]
[Narrator:] And, neglected baby teeth can cause permanent teeth to come in damaged and irregular.
Give your child the gift of a happy smile.
Your child's first teeth are important.
[Peggy smiles to show her new healthy teeth at the dentist office while her mom and the dentist watch.]
[Little boy eats a lollipop while dressed
as a cowboy.]
[Narrator:] Hold it partner. Old villain tooth
decay is hiding out in your mouth.
Ready to attack your teeth, cause cavities
every time you eat.
[The villainous tooth decay is shown inside
the boy's mouth shooting his teeth with cavity spray.]
[Narrator:] Here's your troubleshooting toothbrush.
It sweeps away food particles.
Helps knock out tooth decay.
[Toothbrush rushes in and wipes away tooth
decay. The boy smiles.]
Remember partner, reach for your toothbrush
after every meal.
[Narrator:] Meet Susie Brown, who wins the
prize for her sparkling smile.
But wait, a trophy also goes to Susie's mother.
[Susie gets a trophy from a man standing on a stepladder. The same man hands her mom a trophy.]
[Narrator:] Mother started taking Susie to
the dentist when she was only two.
He made sure Susie's permanant teeth would grow in sound and straight.
[Susie's mother takes her to the dentist when she was younger and Susie smiles to show her healthy teeth.]
[Narrator:] Be like Susie's mother. Help your child to healthy teeth.
[Narrator:] Funny how we sweat and slave over things which, um, soon go out of style.
[A man is washing his car when another car rides by and splashes water on him.]
[Narrator:] Yet we neglect our teeth. Which,
with care and attention can last a lifetime.
Brush your teeth immediately after eating.
Give them the regular care they need.
[The man brushes his teeth and smiles.]
[Narrator:] Smile your way through life. Your
teeth can last a lifetime.
[A wife and children appear next to the man.]
[Narrator:] Teenage Tommy wins all gals with a secret weapon. His pearly teeth and gleaming grin.
[A girl bypasses another boy to walk side-by-side
with Tommy.]
[Narrator:] The smart set knows too many sweets are for squares. They cause cavities,
make you feel funny about your looks. So snack on fresh fruit, milk, or nuts.
[The boy who was left alone eats some candy while Tommy offers the girl an apple then kisses her on the cheek.]
[Narrator:] Teens with healthy teeth really
rate.
[Music]
[Narrator:] This is Billy. Billy is a little
boy who is always happy and healthy
and who always wears a big smile.
Everyone likes to see Billy smile, for he
has clean, white teeth.
[His family happily watches as Billy joyfully
smiles.]
[Narrator:] But one day not long ago, Billy
noticed that one of his teeth was loose.
Soon it was loose enough to pull out without hurting.
[Billy pulls his tooth out]
[Narrator:] Tonight you should place the tooth
under your pillow, said his mother.
And in the morning you might find a surprise
under your pillow.
[Billy places the tooth under his pillow.]
[Narrator:] So that night Billy placed the
tooth under his pillow.
Soon after falling asleep, he began to dream.
And in his dream he saw his tooth. It was
larger than a tooth really is,
and it could move and talk.
Hello, it said. I'm Tommy Tooth. I just wanted
to say goodbye.
Why must you go away, Billy asked Tommy Tooth,
setting him on his knee.
Because you are growing up, and you need a
big grown-up tooth, Tommy Tooth answered.
Since you were a very little boy, I have helped
you chew your food.
I have stood straight in line, so you could
speak clearly and have a nice smile.
But now, I am no longer big enough to do the job well.
So a bigger tooth will soon fill the space I am leaving.
[Tommy Tooth lies down]
[Narrator:] And...*yawns*... I should take
a nice long rest somewhere.
But before I go, let me warn you, said Tommy Tooth.
Your new tooth must last you the rest of your life, so take good care of it.
For good health you should have meat, vegetables and fruits, milk, and bread or cereal every day.
Be careful about what you eat and when you eat it.
For instance, sweets eaten between meals can spoil your appetite.
[Billy rejects his dinner because he has eaten
sweets between meals.]
[Narrator:] Also, because they are sticky,
sweets cling to your teeth.
And sweet foods that stick to the teeth can
cause your teeth a lot of damage
if not cleaned off immediately.
That is why you should clean your teeth right
after eating, if possible.
If you do not have your toothbrush with you
when you're away from home,
eating an apple will help clean your teeth,
and apples taste good, too.
[Billy eats an apple]
[Narrator:] Besides, apples and other fruits
give you vitamins and minerals and lots of energy.
Finally, you should have a dentist look at
your teeth regularly.
If you do all of these things carefully, especially
while you are growing up
you will keep your second teeth a long, long time.
Even as long as you live.
But now, you must go back to sleep, for rest is also important.
Goodbye, said Billy.
And thank you. I'll remember what you told
me.
And with that Billy's dream ended and he went
on sleeping peacefully.
[Birds chirp outside]
[Billy wakes up and checks under his pillow,
finding money in place of the tooth.]
[Narrator:] The next morning, instead of the
tooth under his pillow,
he found a bright shiny coin.
Billy showed his mother the coin and told
her about the dream.
The dentist has told you the same things before,
his mother said.
But now that Tommy Tooth told you in your
dream, you will remember better than ever.
And do you know, Billy did remember.
[Animated bulldozers are heading to a construction
site.]
[Narrator:] Few sights so stir the heart of
man. Few opportunities so fire his imagination
as...yes...the chance to be a sidewalk superintendent!
[Men rush to line up a sign that reads For
Sidewalk Superintendents]
[Narrator:] For example, here comes Henry
J. Whortle, on his way to an important appointment.
[Henry:] Heya, Hey, Hey, Hey what's going
on? Hey, let me through.
[Henry pushes his way through the group  men where he can see through the hole in the gate.]
[Henry:] Ohhhhhhh, they're fixing the bridge.
Say, there that looks like a big
mouth. With a tooth missing. What'd I say?
[Narrator:] What's the matter Henry? Does
that remind you of your own missing...
[Henry opens his mouth to reveal one of his
bottom teeth is missing.]
[Narrator:] But what's a missing tooth? You
have more important things to think about.
[Henry:] Oh sure. Sure I have. And say, why
all the fuss? There's only one measly little
stone missing out of that great big bridge.
[Narrator:] Glad you brought that up, Henry.
Gives us a chance to show off our newest piece of equipment.
The future-scope.
[A giant machine appears next to Henry]
[Henry:] Future-scope? Eh, what for?
[Narrator:] To foretell the future, naturally.
Here, see what the future of this bridge would be if it weren't being fixed right now.
[Henry:] Uh, what do I do?
[Narrator:] Just dial to Bridge and press
the button. It's a big bridge but like you
said, just one measly little stone is missing.
[Henry:] Heya, Hey, Hey look the other stones
are moving.
The whole bridge is getting out of shape. Ohhhhhhh.
[A stone that came out of the bridge falls
out on the future scope and hits Henry's foot.]
[Henry:] Ouch. Hmm, just one stone starting
all that.
[Narrator:] That's what could happen if they
didn't do something about it.
[Henry:] Uhh hey. This future-scope work on
people too?
[Narrator:] Yes.
[Henry:] Me, maybe? Could it show me five,
ten years from now? Like Charles Boyer maybe.
[A man in a Middle Eastern style hat speaks
to a woman passing him.]
[Stranger in hat:] Darling, come with me to
the casbah.
[Narrator:] Go on, try it.
[Henry:] Hahaha, I can hardly wait. Say, uh,
Whortle, Henry J.
[The name Whortle, Henry J. appears on the
future scope.]
[Henry:] Ehhh wait why do I.. this can't be.
There must be some mistake.
[Future Henry:] The future-scope never makes
mistakes.
[Henry:] A handsome guy like me. How, how,
how could it happen?
[Henry thinks about the bridge falling apart.]
[Henry:] That can happen to me? Urghh because
I lost one measly tooth?
[Narrator:] Henry. Your teeth are like a stone
bridge in many ways.
Durable. Meant to last a lifetime.
But like the stones in the bridge, your teeth
depend upon each other for support.
[Henry:] Lose one tooth and I can be in for
trouble?
[Narrator:] Yes. Starting with children, it's
wrong to ignore a missing tooth.
When youngsters lose their first teeth too
early,
a space maintainer can prevent their teeth from shifting.
If this is not done, the permanent teeth can
come in crooked or out of place.
It can spoil a child's smile for life.
[A little girl loses a tooth and grows up
with a ruined smile.]
[Henry:] So what about me?
[Narrator:] We'll show you. Grown-ups should
have the missing tooth replaced, too,
with a bridge. If it is not replaced...well, just look.
[An x-ray of a mouth is shown with other teeth
drifting into the space where a tooth is missing.]
[Narrator:] The other teeth may start drifting into the empty space.
These irregularly spaced teeth are harder to clean. So it is easier to get cavities.
And because the teeth don't come together
properly, there's liable to be gum and bone injury.
If you neglect it, there may be infection
of the tissue around the teeth.
[X-ray of teeth shows gum and bone injury
as well as possible places of infection.]
[Narrator:] And eventually this could lead
to the loss of all your teeth.
[Henry puts his hand over his mouth]
[Henry:] All my teeth!? I never realized.
Just letting one tooth go.
Why didn't somebody tell me? Somebody did. I just remembered.
My dentist. That's what my important appointment
was. I'm late. Gangwayyyyy!
[Narrator:] [laughter] Henry's lucky. He realized in time
the damage just one missing tooth can do. How about you?
[Henry runs past the bridge and goes straight to the dentist.]
[Music]
[Screen goes dark.]